we've been wondering for a while now and
sort of asking questions
about whether we can trust the
coronavirus numbers that we're getting
and part of the reason why that's been
in question is that there have been
reports that individual states were
choosing to suppress
data maybe not so much about cases but
possibly about deaths florida was one
place where we heard those allegations
made
very specifically but now we have to
talk about this at the federal level
because there are growing reports that
the trump administration
is coordinating a suppression effort
to prevent the real numbers about
coronavirus from getting out
and we've actually gotten our hands on a
memo that was sent out
which specifically says to hospitals as
of today
july 15 stop sending the data to the cdc
instead send it to the department of
health and human services
run by trump tool and sycophant
alex azar this is exactly
what we predicted might happen months
ago if the numbers did not
improve the new york times reported
yesterday that hospitals have been
ordered to bypass
the normal process the normal process is
hospitals report to the cdc
and they were told send us all of your
data send it directly to the department
of health and human services
this is the opposite of transparency
this opens the door
to just hiding the data and health
experts obviously are alarmed because
they know exactly how this can go now we
eventually got a copy of the order
from the trump administration and what
the document says to hospitals is
uh don't send your information to the
cdc send it to us
and of course that is a department the
department of health and human services
that is run by the guy trump picked and
who has been brown-nosing trump since
the start of this pandemic
and in all of history since the cdc was
created
pandemic data health data like what
we're dealing with today
goes to the cdc the kaiser family
foundation which has no connection
whatsoever to the insurance company
kaiser permanente the kaiser family
foundation
says quote this is jen cates the
director of global health and hiv policy
jen kate says historically the cdc has
been the place where public health data
has been sent
and this raises questions i love the
understated nature this raises questions
about not just access for researchers
but access for reporters
access for the public to try to better
understand what is happening with the
outbreak
how will the data be protected will
there be transparency will there be
access
and what is the role of the cdc in
understanding the data now you need only
zoom out
like the tiniest bit to understand what
is most likely going on here
donald trump admitted that he wanted to
slow down testing in order to cover up
the reality
of the pandemic remember he said one of
the reasons we have so many cases
is we have so many tests now this
ignores a whole bunch of realities in
fact
if you don't test it doesn't affect the
real number of cases
except it probably increases the real
number of cases
because without testing people don't
know they have the virus and they go out
and they spread it so not testing
actually
spreads the disease additionally as
testing has gone up in many of the
states that are worst affected
the positivity rate has gone up if you
go from
thousand to ten thousand tests a day and
you go from having two percent of the
people test positive to four percent
that is a signal of a growing epidemic
this is all way beyond donald trump he
doesn't seem to understand any of this
stuff so
the point is once you understand trump
admitted
to wanting to slow down testing to slow
down case numbers
and you see that the trump
administration is saying to hospitals
don't send your data to the cdc
send your data to alex azar at hhs the
obvious next step is to start covering
up this data cover up death data cover
up hospitalization data
the white house is trying to muzzle the
normal reporting process
and the only reason that that exists
is to suppress information if he can't
stop the testing
he'll stop the information now i'm
hoping i don't i don't know
i've talked to a few people today and
they have different opinions like could
this work
because there are other ways to get the
data out
media will talk to hospitals and
hospitals will say
well we'll say we're full we have no
room in the icu for example
and at a certain point if the data
that the trump administration is
allowing to be published
says one thing that goes completely
against what
the icu information is at a certain
point
you would hope that it would explode
that the real
data has been covered up i don't know i
mean i'm hopeful that this can't really
be covered up to this degree
but the administration has decided the
numbers must go down the numbers have to
go down
for the benefit of donald trump's
re-election here's one way to do it
now what we can hope for is that we
still
find the data and that trump is punished
electorally for trying to suppress the
data rather than dealing with the
pandemic itself
it's too early to know which way it will
go because the directive starts today
it's effective as of july 15th so we'll
have to see what happens
but what we need to understand is that
from this point forward from
as if this wasn't already the case in
many of the states in the united states
already
um from this point forward we have to
realize
that the numbers that make it out may
not be the real numbers
because the idea is hide the data to
justify
a faster economic opening to help donald
trump get himself reelected his
re-election
is the most important factor it's far
more important than american lives and
it's really the only thing you need to
know
to understand how to analyze the actions
of this administration
it seems to run counter to health it
seems to run counter to common sense
it seems short-sighted in terms of the
economy because the relapse effect will
hurt the economy
you just have to understand trump thinks
it might help him get reelected in
november that's all that's going on
the pandemic response has been blown so
badly
that there's really no way to fix it
before the election i was looking at
some data today
and this is important for you to
understand when new york hit its peak
right around april 12 april 15 something
like that that's when new york had its
peak of cases
it took two full months with strict
lockdowns
for new york cases to come down remember
that deaths
lag cases by about 15 to 20 days
so by okay april may june by mid-june
you finally had this improving in new
york and
only in the last 10 days in july have
new york's death numbers
really finished coming down to you know
a number that hopefully
they won't spike again from so you take
that model
two months for cases and then another 15
or so days
for deaths if arizona and florida
and texas fully lock down today
if they don't even want to but if they
did that
you're looking at september 15th to get
cases under control
and october 1st to get what is the
coming spike of deaths
back under control they're not willing
to do it i mean yeah greg abbott now is
saying more
you got to wear a mask but these are not
places that seem to have an appetite
politically or economically or in any
other way
for a full lockdown so trump recognizes
the numbers aren't going to be under
control when you get to 10
15 000 cases a day that doesn't just go
away
in two weeks they are going to be
dealing with widespread
outbreaks until close to election time
if we have the surging second wave by
then it could be even worse
we're now hearing from the cdc that this
fall may be one of the most
difficult times in american history from
the standpoint of public health
so what can trump do just lie cover up
the data that's all that they can do
hide the data use the data well
use the data you're willing to publish
which is not accurate to say we should
reopen
reopen in order to make things seem
normal so that people will vote for you
in the fall
hopefully the real data makes it out but
this is now taking on
the sort of color of a full
cover up because the actual remember it
would have been
rather than covering up data changing
reporting procedure all of this stuff
it would have been much easier to just
deal with the virus from the get-go
that's not what this administration
chose to do